horror fans are serious about continuity
and the complicated mess of sequels
prequels and reboots released after Toby
hoopers The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
don't make it easy to follow in 1998 the
director's son William Hooper added his
own entry to the Canon with All-American
Massacre a 1970s set prequel to The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre 2 that has never
been publicly released the film's
biggest bonus is that it includes actor
Bill Mosley reprising the role of Chop
Top Leatherface's deranged brother it
also promised to delve into the origin
story of the murderous Sawyer Family
years later William turned to
Kickstarter to complete post-production
but failed to secure the 8 000 funding
possibly due to the trailer that
accompanied The Campaign which struck
some fans as amateurish the film's
Facebook page has gone from intermittent
updates to silence so it's possible the
film will never see the light of day
meanwhile the franchise has migrated
from Studio to Studio with the latest
reboot Texas Chainsaw Massacre released
by Netflix in 2022